I can't be good
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
hmm is that giant terrifying ladybug
supposed to be there ha great question
too honey
no no it's not I have no idea why any of
this is happening or how to control it
should we run away then yes
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on why are there giant
animals everywhere
do you hear ariana grande playing why is
everyone wearing blue and yellow you're
not you're the only one who's not
Eleanor this is all happening because of
you we don't know this is because of me
Eleanor this place is a perfectly made
Swiss watch and you are a wrench in the
gears actually you're a hammer just
smashing the gears in the dust
oh hey not everybody here is perfect
okay honey is totally condescending and
there are a couple of you know jokesters
oh I'm just saying I'm not the only one
with flaws so how can we be sure this is
my fault you hugged all the strenght and
now there's shrimp flying around you
call to honey into Rath and now there
are giraffes everywhere okay fine turns
out there are many ways to know that it
was me let's just face it Eleanor
you don't belong here well then this
system sucks what one in a million gets
to live in paradise and everyone else is
tortured for eternity come on I mean I
wasn't freaking Gandhi but I was okay I
was a medium person I should get to
spend eternity in a medium place like
Cincinnati everyone who wasn't perfect
but wasn't terrible should get to spend
eternity in Cincinnati look apparently
he doesn't work that way
I'm sorry Eleanor but there's nothing
anyone can do unless there is something
we can do unless you could teach me
teach you what how'd it be good that was
your job right a professor of ethics
no one knew I was a problem when I
arrived things only started getting
crazy after I was an [ __ ] to everyone
at the party oh you know I'm trying to
say ash hole and not ash hole right I
got that yes okay give me a chance
let me earn my place here let me be your
ethical guinea pig hey guys
emergency neighborhood meeting now we'll
be right there Michael if I walk out of
here in these clothes I'm toast my soul
is in your hands
soul mate what's gonna be
you